[Music]
now you all know that normally i like to
have
fun on this show as much fun as i am
constitutionally capable of having
anyway which isn't much so never mind
the point is that today i have to get
very serious and
even a little emotional perhaps
you probably remember that i began this
week in a state of elation deeply proud
of the fact that my children's book
johnny the walrus about a boy who
identifies as a walrus had not only
become one of the top five best-selling
books on amazon but it also made it onto
amazon's lgbt book list where it was
number one
my walrus novel had had only been on
sale for a few days but already it was
the most popular piece of lgbt
literature in the world topping the list
and beating out such lgbt titles as
filthy bromance and um holigay and
daddy's little christmas these are all
real titles by the way even it even
bested the classic sexted by santa
thrust into love book four
they probably should have stuck with
sexted by santa trilogy you know the
narrative really lost its momentum in
the fourth installment some critics are
reporting anyway um kind of a kind of a
naked cash grab in more ways than one
you might say but in any case
i had suddenly become the most prominent
influential celebrated and revered lgbt
voice in the world
and possibly in all of history
i didn't expect to be put in that
position but i was ready to fulfill the
responsibilities of that office
faithfully
i had big plans for the lgbt movement of
which i was now the sole and
unquestioned leader
yes it's true that i am heterosexual but
there's no reason why
that should should exclude me from
holding this title
i am a straight lgbt author
and leader
and walrus awareness advocate
these are all parts of my
complex and intersectional identity i am
an enigma
even to myself
my identity is a vast mosaic of
different elements and pieces all adding
up to one beautiful yet complicated
whole and from these mysterious depths
sprang forth the work of tortured genius
known as johnny the walrus does all this
sound extremely narcissistic and
nonsensical perhaps
but that only again proves why i deserve
to be the voice of the lgbt movement
which is what i am
yet in an act of mutiny
and treason
my fellow lgbt activists turned on me
they complained bitterly about the fact
that my book was on the lgbt charts
they were envious
indeed they didn't want it on any charts
at all i reported yesterday that media
matters had published a hit piece
accusing me of transphobia and other
assorted thought crimes glad the gay and
lesbian alliance against defamation
aligned itself with my defamers
calling on amazon to remove the book
from the lgbt category
other activists chimed in some of them
tagging jeff bezos calling on amazon's
founder to address the matter personally
in the greatest act of betrayal
my favorite website
the gay news site pink news published an
article with this title
right wing pundit gloats as amazon lists
hateful transphobic book as lgbt plus
bestseller
and the article explains amazon has
listed a hateful transphobic children's
book by the daily wires matt walsh as
its number one best-selling lgbt book
walsh a right-wing writer who has
compared gender affirming health care to
experimentation molestation abuse and
rape recently announced that he has
written a horrific horrific anti-trans
children's book johnny the walrus set to
be published in march the book began
taking pre-orders this month on amazon
which is
inexplicable inexplicably classed it as
an lgbt book in review the right-wing
publication the blaze said matt walsh's
work is an effort to push back against
radical gender ideology which defies
biological reality
but if anything says ideology surely
it's a book that tells children that
expressing their gender means being
forced to eat worms and having their
feet cut off
johnny the walrus supposedly aimed at
three to five-year-olds tells the story
of a little boy who pretends to be a
walrus johnny's mother is pressured by
the internet to tell her child that he
is a walrus and protesters are shown
with signs claiming human walruses are
real walruses the most twisted attack on
trans kids is when johnny's mom takes
him to the doctor who tells him he must
only eat worms constantly wear itchy
gray makeup and have his feet cut into
fins well i just opened my christmas
present which is a set of kamikoto
knives
and uh look these knives they tap into
more than 800 years of traditional
techniques from honshu japan each
kamikota knife goes through a rigorous
19-step process that takes several years
from start to finish to complete because
of their single bevel edge kamikoto
knives can achieve an unbelievably sharp
edge
and
they can cut through your rib eye like
butter they can cut through anything or
any one i'm just kidding don't cut
people chemical knives are used by
several chefs working at a michelin star
restaurant and uh when you get these
knives you can tell why so click the
link below or go to
matt walsh and use kamikodo.com code
matt walsh to save an extra 50 today now
for the record
if that part of the story is an attack
on anyone it would be an attack on
people who mutilate kids not on the kids
themselves obviously this is like if
you're punching somebody in the face and
i tell you to stop and you accuse me of
attacking the person that you were
punching so you're the attacker in that
situation i am the intervener in the
attack that's how that relationship
works
but anyway the greater point here
is that the very people who ought to
have been coming to my aid and defending
me as a straight gay icon
were instead focused on marginalizing me
and their campaign of hate and bigotry i
am sad to report has worked
this morning i awoke to discover that
johnny the walrus the most courageous
piece of lgbt literature ever written
has been removed from amazon's lgbt
bestseller list they took it off
no explanation
they didn't ask me
i didn't consent
and it's not just that there that there
had been a surge and sexted by santa
sales supplanting my book as number one
if that were the case i would tip my cap
to the sexting santa and accept defeat
but that's not what happened
i was removed from the category entirely
i have been literally erased
i've been targeted for violence not
literal violence but literary violence
justice millett was not the victim of an
anti-gay hate crime but i am
i'm also a better fiction writer
incidentally this is an attack not just
on on on me
but on the whole lgbt community
and on the walrus community
i feel i have to say deeply
afraid now
unsafe
i mean if i cannot be safe and secure on
the amazon lgbt list
then where can i turn
where am i safe
i have represented and defended the lgbt
community faithfully for these many
hours
who will defend me now
no one
i feel alone
and cold
and abandoned
but i have cried all the tears uh i can
cry over this i'm sure there'll be many
tears in the future
i have been dehumanized de-legitimized
decertified vaporized
but i'm not gonna back down
i'm still gonna stand up and be loud and
proud and speak my truth
a truth which is grounded in my lived
experience as an lgbt author and walrus
advocate
amazon can't stop me nobody can i'm not
going to be canceled instead to glaad
and pink news and amazon and media
matters with all the strength i can
muster as a best-selling lgbt author a
title i will retain forever by the way
i say that you all
are canceled
shame on you
shame on you
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content